el impacto ambiental de los incendios en
Canadá ha cruzado la frontera y ha
llegado hasta Estados Unidos donde el
viento ha llevado a la contaminación del
humo y el aire empieza a verse afectado
en grandes ciudades como Nueva York
Incluso el alcalde neoyorquino Erick
Adams pidió a los ciudadanos que
extremen las precauciones
si usted es un neoyorquino con problemas
cardíacos o respiratorios tenga cuidado
cuando esté al aire libre el humo de los
incendios forestales de Canadá está
afectando al aire de nuestra ciudad por
lo que se ha emitido un aviso sanitario
sobre la calidad del aire intenta
limitar hoy las actividades al aire
libre a lo estrictamente necesario
durante el martes la agencia de
protección ambiental emitió una alerta
por la mala calidad del aire en nueva
Inglaterra sumándose a las advertencias
de Illinois Wisconsin y Minnesota la
propagación de las partículas se está
registrando no solo por el aire sino
también por el agua a través del río
Ohio lo que ha elevado la preocupación
de los expertos sobre el nivel de
contaminación de la afluente los niveles
que estamos viendo hoy en día son
Realmente mucho más altos de lo que
normalmente se ve en una gran ciudad
contaminada de Asia por ejemplo
desafortunadamente es probable que estos
niveles se mantengan altos hasta que se
apaguen los incendios en Canadá el
panorama para sofocar el fuego no es
alentador solamente en la provincia de
Quebec hay más de 150 focos activos en
una temporada que ya registrado 422
incendios y
226.084 hectáreas dañadas en lo que va
del año